[Gelächter]
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen wir heute zu einem
neuen club auf einem kanal meine damen
und herren gehört zum stadl stoffe sind
so ein auto der fackelt sicherheit hey
warum sitzen im auto wohlfahrt ihr denn
wir fahren nicht irgendwie nach lieber
an von köln oder keine ahnung was wir
fahren nach amsterdam
wir haben uns auf jeden fall gedacht hey
es wäre langweilig wenn wir einfach so
ohne grund nach amsterdam fahren also
einfach nur chillen die stars also klar
ist jetzt nicht weit vom cayman fertigen
die zweieinhalb stunden aber ich habe
diese brille wieder gefunden das ist die
brille mit der ich schon mal eine
challenge auf einem kanal gemacht habe
auf jeden fall haben wir die brille
mitgenommen und werde nun mit dieser
brille nach amsterdam fahren und einfach
ein paar sachen machen wie wir sagen
erste challenge ist er wie tanken jetzt
wird dieser brille
das hat voll gut geklappt ich dachte
jetzt ja auch dass die ganze zeit erst
dagegen aber okay das war gut der sitzt
jetzt zum ersten mal diese brille
ob er sich gesagt das ist nicht die
polizei es ist nicht eben von der brille
die irgendwie für 34 euro kostet sondern
das gegenkonzept nichts der siteco
wirklich irgendwie 80 90 euro
ich bin hier die brille wird wirklich
weil so einsätze eingesetzt wenn man so
aufstellen wird über drogen und so
weiter und so fort
von daher ist das wirklich so ein ding
was wirklich professionell ist sage ich
mal
und damit fangen jetzt weiter nach
amsterdam und wollen in amsterdam
pacellis damit leute zweiter stock
mittlerweile hier raucherpause wir haben
eben auto von max oma einen kleinen
golfball gefunden und jetzt haben uns
gedacht dass wir jetzt diese brille
aufsetzen die erste challenge machen und
zwar mit diesem ball bzw
wir waren ja schon tanken gerade aber
jetzt diesen ball in diese mühle
reinwerfen da sieht man nicht richtig
sagen mein hof war ziemlich beschissen
aber ab dem eintritt zu finden was die
autobahn
[Musik]
jetzt gepackt wurde ist alles voll mit
käse habt jetzt viel zu stecken trotzdem
noch käse alle folgen haben und zwar
startet man an dieser laterne hier
hier läuft bei los mit der brille man
läuft bis zu dieser analyse sind
irgendwie 20 30 meter hab ich doch in
der brille wird recht interessant 3
und stoppt acht sekunden 35 32 19
nachdem wie die schneller 321 kommen
[Musik]
maikammer zweifeln hauptsache hier sind
wir vorhin so das rennen gelaufen so
richtig beschreiben diese alkohol brille
und hier vorne ist einfach eine
bibliothek für die leute so lernen und
irgendwann die welt regieren und
studieren in deutschland hat sich sogar
drauf solopart tüten und so wasser nur
so aus glasflaschen die hier schlug
eiskalt rinne und fahrrad nur wenige
minuten später jeden tag ausgeliehen
heute noch jeden tag damit jetzt jeder
mal mit der alkohol brille mit dem
fahrrad fährt man ahnt dass sie legal
ist aber wie man's macht
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
auch noch mal fahren
man kann sich das halt wirklich glaube
ich nicht vorstellen wenn man irgendwie
zuschauern aber ich kann euch mal den
link von ihrer brille und wenn die
beschreibung kostet 98 euro oder so aber
das heißt wirklich professionell die das
alter noch ziemlich gut ziemlich gut das
ding ist so hier ist halb voll die
idyllische stadt zu amsterdam hauptstadt
weltstadt keine ahnung was das update
mit dieser saison ausgeliehen fahrrad
unserer alkohol brille alter der mega zu
limonade von so kleinen kindern richtig
gut
[Musik]
wer kleine kinder kennen gelernt die
verkaufen die limonade und fotos mit
denen macht das die habe ich vielleicht
wirkstoffen hochgeladen die letzten fünf
minuten bestand haben wir fahren oft mit
seiner brille rum und die machen das
geschäft ihres lebens das fahrer duo
abgeben weil die um 6 zu machen
das ist meine rechnung von dem
fahrradverleih gewesen und ab dem
eintritt in den korb ihr also nicht so
mit brille ich pizza wie schön ist diese
stadt leute guckt euch einfach mal das
gebäude dann wenn egal wo man hinkommt
überall dingen die so voll schön aus und
dann halt wieder updaten dass er ganz
hinten am ende der straße bewegt sich
irgendwo ein palast oder schloss anders
sein bei der hauptbahnhof wie schön ist
einfach diese hauptbahnhof wir sind
jetzt hier noch in diesen becken hof
oder irgendwie sowas ein bisschen
einkaufen
merck kannst du lesen wie es der preis
da drauf ist
279 anwesend wie ein parkhaus angekommen
und haben unser praktiker bezahlt mit
achten dass vor günstig einer 60 stunden
15 minuten bis vier stunden in amsterdam
an
ich habe 30 euro wir sitzen jetzt wieder
im auto fahren zurück nach köln und
sehen uns dort wie da der lkw
transportiert einfach von außen vor
2000 jahre später 50.000 jahre autofahrt
später das vor ein paar tagen schon bei
einer instagram gesagt ich wohne
wirklich seit mehr als fünf jahren in
köln und ich war jetzt zweimal nachts im
dom wie groß die größer als ich werde
mir dadurch jetzt haben auch ganz
spontan channels getroffen
schänis probiert jetzt die alkohol
brille runter meint dass gerade das
selbst noch nie alkohol getrunken
nein das ist nicht so dass ich sie zum
ersten mal farben und darunter vogue
calgary
übrigens gerade angekommen sind wir
gerade in düsseldorf in der sucht eine
wohnung und er findet keiner deswegen
falls jemand von euch in düsseldorf
zufällig eine wohnung hat schreibt alle
lokale freut sich falls das essen noch
mal wieder übel hat die sache irgendwie
gefühlt seit 70 jahren in diesem blog
dass mir nach hause fahren und in meinem
zuhause sind in köln werden wir noch
richtig auf alvi zu antep im schönen
döner fressen die griechen die spulen
adria um 12 uhr
jetzt kann ich endlich sagen das ist die
brille von dann gefallen ist kaiser
robbie ich sagen meine lieben freunde
wir sind wieder zu hause angekommen
richtig bei mir in der wohnung ich habe
ich habe besser wir sind auf jeden fall
wieder in meiner wohnung hier in köln
angekommen
wir haben uns wirklich wie gesagt
einfach gestern abend gedacht mit diesen
dingen noch mal ich habe eine story
macht auf instagram haben uns halt
gedacht hey kommen das verlustjahr
ganzen box machen sagt spontan gesagt er
komme dass nach amsterdam fahren wird
erteilt von köln irgendwie zwei drei
stündchen länger mal gesagt kommen tages
tritt er mit der brille auf jeden fall
ganz lustig ich wollte jetzt nicht den
ganzen block in dem papier und 20 uhr
mit der brille nennen weil das wetter
nicht richtig gewesen sondern wären es
ein falsches gemacht und es euch gefällt
hat das gerne wir gucken jetzt auf jedes
die serie genau wir schauen dass noch
eine serie und dann gehen wir auch
[Musik]